ich habe sie vorhin zitiert ich bin das
Gesicht zu aktuellen Baukrise haben sie
neulich den Kollegen vom Spiegel glaube
ich gesagt und das fühlt sich nicht gut
an fühlt sich nicht gut an oder ist auch
ungerechtfertigt
also das war eine lange Forderung der
mobilen und wohnungs- und Bauwirtschaft
das ist wieder ein eigenes
baumministerium gibt weil wir in der Tat
in den letzten Jahren großen Reformstau
hatten bei der Frage Digitalisierung
Vorfertigung Abbau von vielen vielen
Sachen die unsere Planungsprozesse ganz
C und lange und damit auch teuer machen
und wir
haben dieses Ministerium gegründet
eigentlich auf einer Hochphase der
Baukonjunktur und die ist dann je
natürlich mit dem 24 Februar quasi
abrupt beendet zum einen natürlich wegen
dieser Schwierigkeiten aufgrund der
Sanktionen aber noch viel dramatischer
natürlich wegen der Zinsen und diese
Zinsen die ja so niedrig waren in den
letzten Jahren haben ganz viel geformt
Stau überdeckt weil man sich dann halt
das auch noch leisten konnte wenn es
100.000 € teurer geworden ist weil die
Kapitalkosten so niedrig sind und jetzt
haben wir den geformter und große
Kapitalkosten und das führt jetzt zum
Einbruch auch der
bauantragszahlen und das justament in in
dem Moment wo die Bundesregierung nach
langer langer Zeit wieder im
Bauministerium hat ein Bruch heißt was
also wir haben einen deutlichen Rückgang
der
bauantragszahlen die zehn Prozent oder
also es geht schon in Richtung minus 20
- 25 Prozent das ist alles sehr schwer
einzuschätzen was das dann in den
fertigungsstellungen Zahlen heißt weil
wir haben gleichzeitig ein Bau Überhang
also genehmigte Bauten von über 800.000
das heißt wir haben schon noch genug
planungsregierung und die werden nicht
gebaut doch aber es gab in den letzten
Jahren natürlich eine extrem hohe
Auslastung der Bauwirtschaft das hat ja
jeder gemerkt der privaten versucht hat
ein Handwerker zu kriegen das heißt wir
hatten Material Lieferschwierigkeiten
und wir hatten Schwierigkeiten mit dem
Bau Fortschritt das heißt wurde immer
länger die Bauzeiten und deswegen hat
sich quasi in dieser Phase wo ganz
vielen Bauantrag gestellt haben so ein
richtig großer Berg angehäuft von großen
ähm bauüberhängt allerdings jetzt die
Zahlen sind sehr sehr dramatisch und wir
beobachten das intensiv weil die
Auslastung ist jetzt natürlich noch hoch
aber wenn das weiter so geht droht
natürlich auch da das was ich auf gar
keinen Film will nämlich dass Firmen
anfangen Kapazitäten abzubauen das wäre
ganz dramatisch weil das hat man in der
gastrosszene gesehen Mitarbeiter die
erstmal weg sind die kommen auch nicht
so nicht wieder das heißt hier muss auch
durch staatliche Unterstützung dann auch
Nachfrage generiert werden wie also wir
haben jetzt zum Beispiel ein Programm
gestartet für 500 Millionen junges
Wohnen das heißt Ausbildungs- und
Studentenwohnheime das ist das größte
Programm dieser Art seit der
Wiedervereinigung und wir haben 14,5
Milliarden in den sozialen Wohnungsbau
gesteckt der war ja fast in
Vergessenheit geraten war nur noch eine
ganz kleine Nische und das ist natürlich
jetzt auch in dieser Situation eine
Stabilisierung für die
Wohnungswirtschaft und wir haben ein
Programm klimafreundlich erneuerbar
allerdings auch mit sehr viel Holzbau
muss ich gestehen natürlich auch richtig
wo wir dann auch noch mal eine
Zinssubvention machen und im Sommer
startet auch ein Programm für junge
Familien die sich ein Haus bauen wollen
mal ganz kurz mal die die Dimension Olaf
Scholz wir haben das plakata gerade
gesehen war der Kanzler der sozusagen
das war eines der ganz zentralen
wahlversprechend 400.000 neue Wohnungen
pro Jahr
Kanzler für bezahlbares Wohnen sie
weisen zu Recht auf den 24 Februar hin
auf auf den Angriff auf die Ukraine
nichtsdesto weniger hatten wir auch zu
dem Zeitpunkt schon massiv das Thema wir
haben gar nicht die Leute die das Bauen
können wo stehen wir heute wie viele
Wohnungen haben im vergangenen Jahr
gebaut sie waren sich eben nicht so
Sicherstellung kommt immer im Mai das
heißt in einem Monat können wir darüber
reden wie viel wir
sind doch nee also
ich habe letzte Woche hatte ich den
Besuch der Chefin des äh Statistikamtes
des Bundes die weiß es selber noch nicht
weil die Meldungen aus den Ländern
kommen immer erst am Ende April und dann
wird die gesamtstatist
ja es gibt ganz viel Spekulationen wir
hatten uns folgen unterhalten sie haben
in Ulm so viel fertiggestellt wie lange
nicht mehr gleichzeitig sind natürlich
auch jetzt die Bremsspuren zu sehen das
heißt das kann sein dass wir in etwa das
Niveau vom Vorjahr erreicht haben aber
im Vorjahr waren 291
000 das war 20021 das letzte 300.000
knapp 300.000 irgendwie so das ist aber
das große Ziel sind ja die 400 deswegen
ist es jetzt auch egal um das einmal mal
in den richtigen Kontext zu stellen ja
sicherlich aufgrund der Tatsache dass ja
viele Menschen aus der Ukraine auch noch
zu uns gekommen sind sind das mehr als
die 400.000 und es merken ja viele 600
da gibt es jetzt unterschiedliche Zahlen
es ist ja auch egal ob es nur 100 oder
200 300 000 ähm wir müssen die Kapazität
wir müssen die Kapazitäten ausweiten
weil die 300.000 die wir jetzt schaffen
wenn alles super läuft sind auf jeden
Fall zu wenig und ein Punkt gerade mit
Blick auf den Fachkräftemangel ist
natürlich sehr heller Wohnungsbau und
das habe ich gleich von Anfang an gesagt
dass wir das brauchen werden da habe ich
als ostpolitikerin gleich immer diese
Marzahn Hellersdorf Fotos und meine
Interviews gekriegt mittlerweile
passiert extrem viel ich war jetzt in
München auf der Baumesse also modulares
bauen serielles bauen nimmt Fahrt auf
und das ist die Grundlage damit wir
überhaupt wieder so viel bauen können
wie früher aber zu wenig oder können sie
lösen wie viele Wohnungen brauchen wir
ungefähr ich habe vorhin die 700.000
zitiert das ist eine Zahl genau kursiert
die 700.000 ist das was stand Anfang des
Jahres gesamt fehlt also das was meine
über die Jahre aufgestaut hat also wenn
wir 700.000 Wohnungen zusätzlich hätten
sagen mehrere wohnungsverbände dann wäre
das Problem halbwegs gelöst was das
letzte Jahr angeht gibt es bislang
tatsächlich nur die Schätzungen von den
bauverbänden da sind die optimistischen
so bei 280.000 die nicht mehr ganz so
optimistischen bei 250.000 aber quasi
das letzte Jahr war was da gebaut wurde
das wurde ja drei vier Jahre vorher
angestoßen also noch zu einer guten
Zeiten werden
sehen ja die Krise über die wir jetzt
reden die werden wir tatsächlich erst in
zwei drei Jahren sehen wenn nämlich dann
all die Projekte die jetzt gestoppt
werden für dies war auch schon
Genehmigung gibt aber die eben einfach
nicht mehr gebaut werden wenn die dann
auf dem Wohnungsmarkt fehlen da gibt's
eben auch Umfragen also zum Beispiel vom
Verband der Wohnungswirtschaft die haben
ermittelt dass jede dritte Wohnung die
eigentlich jetzt fertig gestellt werden
sollte also die eine Genehmigung hat wo
schon Planung gelaufen sind wo auch
schon jemand Geld reingesteckt hat nicht
mehr gebaut wird einfach weil das von
der Umsetzung her so unglaublich teuer
genau Inflation Baukosten und so weiter
nehmen sie auch so Wahrheit für die
Bundesrepublik sagen aber für die Stadt
Ulm ist es ganz eindeutig also wir
werden dieses Jahr wir haben es eben
Vorgespräch diskutiert wir werden die
höchstens Fertigstellungszahlen haben
seit langem aber das sind nicht die
einzigen Größenordnung von 800 Wohnungen
pro Jahr werden und 700 vorgenommen vor
ich glaube sieben Jahren dass wir sollen
ja oder dieses Jahr ja aber das ist eben
das Problem beim Wohnungsbau dass man
entscheidet etwas hochzufahren dann hat
man die Erfolge vier Jahre später fünf
Jahre später weil man die Verfahren
braucht und dann das Bauen erledigt
werden muss und das was soll der jetzt
gerade gesagt hat ist das Problem dass
das was wir jetzt wahrnehmen
das merken wir in drei vier Jahren weil
wir haben und da sind auch die
Bauanträge und die Baugenehmigungen die
sind bei uns gar nicht so wahnsinnig
zurückgegangen ja wir reden über
zwischen fünf und zehn Prozent aber die
Projekte werden nicht angefangen also
wir merken das ganz viele viele
Vorhabenträger warten das kann sein dass
die in zwei Jahren anfangen das kann
sein dass die in einem Jahr anfangen
oder in drei Jahren aber sie sagen in
derzeitigen Zeitpunkt wo es eine
riesenunsicherheit gibt über die Frage
und das ist schon auch ein Thema was uns
beschäftigt diese wechselnden
förderrahmenbedingungen es gab dieses
Thema dass man nach relativ kurzer Zeit
dann bei der KfW keine Kredite mehr
gekriegt hat
sehr schnell anrufen damit man überhaupt
noch eine Chance hat er was zu bekommen
und Unsicherheit ist sicher das größte
Gift was man hat in einer Unternehmung
die auf mehrere Jahre angelegt ist weil
jeder der sich einlässt auf Klauen der
macht erstmal drei vier Jahre geht er in
Vorleistung bevor er irgendwas da
draußen
Rendite oder Refinanzierung ziehen kann
und da sehe ich tatsächlich große große
Dramatik dass wir in eine Situation
reinlaufen wo wir in drei vier Jahren
ernten was wir jetzt nicht gesät haben
und dann wirklich ein eine soziale
Schieflage bekommen gerade in den
Städten die eine große Nachfrage haben
die auch nicht dadurch zu lösen ist dass
die Leute ins Umland ziehen weil das
zieht ganz andere Schwierigkeiten
mobilitätsfragen und so weiter nach sich
aber die Lage sich was von gesagt Frau
gab es offenbar so verzweifelt dass sie
sagen Mensch dann zieht doch mal raus
aufs Land also
sogar Menschen die wurden sehr sehr
gerne
gezogen weil sie keine Arbeit gefunden
haben und durch Home Office Regelung zum
Beispiel gibt es die Möglichkeit dass
man ganz andere pendlerstrecken mit dem
sehr Verdienst wollen Ticket dem
Deutschland Ticket auch natürlich zu
einem sehr überschaubaren Preis 50 € im
Monat Logistikkosten zur Arbeit das ist
viel weniger als manche jetzt in den
letzten Jahren bezahlt haben für ihr
Zugticket und ich war jetzt vor kurzem
in Baden-Württemberg in Oberreichenbach
da haben die ganz viele ländliche
Struktur und die jungen Menschen die
würden da gerne wohnen bleiben aber es
gibt nur ein Familienhäuser kaufen
Mietwohnung und wenn man bei seinen
Eltern aus dem Kinderhaus aussieht will
man ja nicht gleich ein Einfamilienhaus
gründen und die haben jetzt zum Beispiel
mit Unterstützung des Staates die das
alte Gemeindehaus umgebaut da kommen
jetzt jugendwohnungen rein das ist auch
eine Möglichkeit dass Menschen da wo sie
aufgewachsen sind wohnen bleiben können
Frau Löhr hat viele Leute sehr verärgert
diese macht glaube ich der Kanzler hat
auch darüber nachgedacht ne und sagte
müssen also so habe ich zumindest im
Kopf aber aber gerne die 1,7 Millionen
leerstehenden Wohnungen die es in
Deutschland gibt was ja auch tatsächlich
so ist also gerade eben in sehr
ländlichen Regionen gibt es unglaublich
viel Leerstand also wir haben nicht als
Deutschland insgesamt haben wir keinen
Wohnraummangel sondern der Wohnraum
fehlt da wo die meisten Menschen sind
und klar gibt es immer wieder Gruppen
die gerne auf dem Land wohnen die dort
geboren sind die dort bleiben wollen
oder die auch dahin ziehen wollen aber
Fakt ist halt auch ich meine 77% der
Bevölkerung lebt in Ballungszentren die
meisten Jobs sind da also der Druck auf
die Städte wird immer größer werden und
auch je mehr Zuwanderer zu uns kommen
auch die werden ja in die Städte oder in
die Ballungszentren gehen eben wo die
Jobs sind also das ist
das wird mir jetzt nicht lösen können
indem man den Wohnraum so ein bisschen
anders verteilt und sagt er kommt dann
geht auch ein bisschen raus und das mit
dem 49 euro-ticket ist ganz super
sondern also sie sind bauministerin und
ich glaube die Leute erwarten dass sie
jetzt tatsächlich dann auch dort
zumindest sie können ja nicht selber
bauen aber halt anstoßen dass dort
gebaut wird wo die Nachfrage am größten
ist und das ist eben in den
Ballungszentren und mein Eindruck ist
dass sich da gerade sehr viel Frust im
Land auch aufstaut also weil das Problem
eben jetzt unter der Ampelkoalition
nicht kleiner sondern immer größer wird
also das ist schon glaube ich denke
gefährliche Entwicklung auch mit Blick
auf den nächsten Wahlkampf der ja dann
20 also ich glaube wirklich dass man
beides tun muss man muss natürlich in
den Innenstädten nachverdichten zum
Beispiel oben aufs Dach noch mal drei
Etagen in die Innenhöfe gehen bin jetzt
mal gespannt was mit dem Tempelhofer
fällt in Berlin passiert aber wir müssen
glaube ich drei vier Etagen oben drauf
das verändert dann ja sozusagen die den
das Bild unserer Städte vollkommen wenn
wir das machen ja also ich glaube das
ist wenn man sich anguckt wie die
Grundstückspreise heutzutage gestiegen
sind dann ist das einer der wesentlichen
Faktoren wenn Sie einen neues eine neue
Wohnung bauen ist die Frage wie viel
Zeit ich fürs Grundstück so und
natürlich braucht auch Urbanität eine
gewisse Höhe und ich finde das auch gar
nicht schlimm wenn man aus einem fünf
etagenhaus dann ein sechs sieben oder
acht stückiges macht ich habe mir das in
Frankfurt jetzt angeguckt der
plattensiedlung in Berlin gibt es ganz
viele also das ist ähm sozusagen aus
meiner Sicht eine sehr sinnvolle Nutzung
weil wir müssen natürlich auch Flächen
sparen wenn sie sagen wir wollen den
Wald sein lassen wenn wir die
erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen und wenn
wir einiges tun wofür brauchen müssen
wir beim Neubaufläche sparen
gleichzeitig müssen wir den Bestand der
das auch nutzen das heißt wir müssen
nicht mehr gebrauchte beruflichen zu
Wohnung bauen und ich finde es auch
nicht schlimm wenn man durch einen guten
Ausbau des SBN genau wir haben vorhin
darüber gesprochen die schnell meine
Zukunft von Ulm in Stuttgart sein wird
wenn man durch einen guten Ausbau der
Schieneninfrastruktur auch andersrum
natürlich auch es schafft das Orte
attraktiv werden wo Wohnung leer stehen
ob das nur in Coburg ist oder ein
Chemnitz das sind ja attraktive Städte
ich sage ja nicht die müssen alle
Menschen müssen an ein kleines Dorf wo
es nur eine einzige Bushaltestelle gibt
ich beobachte nur dass es eine
Verschiebung in dem wording der
Bundesregierung gibt das ist nämlich
eben nicht mehr so sehr davon die Rede
ist dass 400.000 Wohnungen entstehen
sollen sondern das jetzt mehr über also
weniger über Neubau geredet wird sondern
recht viel über die Verteilung des
vorhandenen Wohnraums und wie man das
besser hinbekommt und da würde ich sagen
darüber gesprochen dass die 400.000
genau so und das heißt wir müssen mit
Blick auf den Klimaschutz und die
Ressourcen schon und die baukapazitäten
die begrenzt sind müssen wir alle
Potenziale heben das heißt das schon da
ist und nicht genutzt wird müssen wir
attraktiver machen das was umgebaut
werden kann muss in Deutschland leichter
umgebaut werden und natürlich auch
gehört dazu Aufstockung und der Wegfall
von so steinregeln wie Stellplatzsatzung
und anderes damit wir überhaupt sprechen
das ist ja eine
Rakete nach der anderen kommst du
nebenbei aber in der Konsequenz heißt
das ja richtig was ne ich würde gern
zwei Sätze noch zu der Dramatik sagen
die in der letzten Jahr bei uns passiert
ist weil wir reden über ländliches bauen
und so weiter aber das Bauen dort ist ja
nicht viel günstiger die
Grundstückspreise sind günstiger aber
das was einfach wenn man das kurz
beschreibt was in dem letzten Jahr in
Ulm passiert ist unsere
Wohnungsbaugesellschaft die sehr stark
ist die sehr sehr gute Projekte macht
und der wir sehr viel arbeiten weil wir
wissen dass sie sehr langfristig auch
bezahlbares Wohnen anbietet hat hat
recht genau
dass diese Wohnungsbaugesellschaft hat
vor zwei Jahren Projekte begonnen mit
einer zielmiete von 12 Euro frei
finanziert das ist eine Miete die ist
für viele Großstädte ein Traum und
hervorragend und ich glaube weit weg von
Problematik wenn Sie genau die gleichen
Projekte jetzt beginnt rechnet sie mit
einer zielmiete von 16 bis 17 Euro das
ist vielleicht für München und Frankfurt
und Stuttgart auch noch eine gute Miete
für Ulm ist es eine praktisch nicht an
den bezahlbar oder bezahlbar vielleicht
schon für einige aber nicht an den Markt
zu bringen und wenn wir dann brauchen
diese Miete weil der Bauträger sonst
auch gar nicht bereit wäre zu bauen
unserer Gesellschaft mit einer
überschaubaren Eigenkapitalrendite ohne
Gewinn also wird nichts ausgezahlt an
den an die Stadt Mutter
noch ein Bauträger dazwischen wäre
anders als jetzt bei ihnen vergiss es
dann ist es eben noch mehr 20 aber ich
will nur den Unterschied beschreiben der
im letzten Jahr passiert ist durch die
Veränderung der Zinsen und der Baupreise
wir haben quasi ein Viertel der Miete
einfach nur in einem Jahr
nach oben bekommen durch die Veränderung
der Rahmenbedingungen dem letzten Jahr
passiert sind und das glaube ich und da
sind wenn wir über Genossenschaften oder
andere sprechen die ihr alle sehr an dem
an den Gestehungskosten orientiert sind
wenn die in ihre Mitgliederversammlung
kommen und sagen letztes Jahr haben wir
ein Projekt starten wollen für 12 Euro
jetzt brauchen wir 17 Euro Miete dann
fliegen die raus dieses Projekt wird
nicht gebaut und das ist wirklich ich
glaube das ist eine Dramatik bei mit um
die wir uns kümmern müssen und die wird
auch mit Geld zu tun haben also die wird
nicht anders lösbar sein dass man in
diesem Segment bauen durch diese ganz
ganz schnelle disruptive Veränderung der
letztes des letzten Jahres auf dass ich
die Bauwirtschaft nicht einstellen kann
dass man dort reagieren muss das heißt
man wird das subventionieren müssen man
da wird man mit Sicherheit auch drüber
nachdenken müssen langfristig hat sich
Bauwirtschaft immer
ausgependelt ja wir hatten schon mal
Zinsen von acht oder zehn Prozent da ist
auch gebaut worden das waren aber
übrigens Zeiten als
Kredit
zinsvergünstigte Kredite für 0,5%
vergeben worden sind als die
Kreditzinsen bei 8% waren in den 70er
Jahren hat man für 0,5% staatliches Geld
für das Bauen von geförderten Wohnungen
dann Laufzeiten über 60 Jahre bekommen
ich glaube dass wir das wieder brauchen
das ist ein ganz zentraler Hebel damit
überhaupt jemand jetzt in den
Wohnungsbau geht weil es macht keiner es
gibt keinen es gibt keinen der
investiert es gibt keinen der dort sich
eine einigermaßen Refinanzierung
erwartet sind das Dinge über die Sie
nachdenken ja wir müssen beides tun das
eine ist dass wir fördern das sozialer
Wohnungsbau diese 14,5 Milliarden die
jetzt von den Ländern deutlich
aufgestockt werden und die Länder haben
ihre Konditionen für die Förderung des
sozialen Wohnungsbaus extrem verbessert
das andere ist wir haben einen
Förderprogramm klimafreundlicher Neubau
mit genau diesen Punkt nämlich der
Zinsverbilligung da haben ganz viele aus
der Branche gesagt hat Frau Geibel das
ist alles so klimafreundlich und
ambitioniert das Geld nimmt ihnen keiner
ab das Gegenteil ist der Fall das läuft
wie geschnitten
Brot und wir diskutieren jetzt gerade
dass wir das so ausstatten dass wir das
bis zum Ende des Jahres auch genau auf
dem Niveau vorziehen können im Sommer
startet das Programm für Familien die
sich ein Haus bauen wollen aber noch mal
das alles über deckt natürlich und ein
bisschen ab dass wir nie ein riesen
reformstar haben weil was wir nicht
machen können ist ja so ein allgemeiner
Baukostenzuschuss für 300 400 500.000
Wohnungen in Deutschland das kann ja
statt niemals bezahlen und deswegen
müssen wir anders bauen preiswerter
bauen und das sind ganz ganz viele
Sachen die gemacht werden müssen
Digitalisierung Bauanträge machen wir
dieses Jahr sehr helle Vorfertigung
modulares bauen das waren die großen
Trends auch jetzt in München weil das
natürlich bei den Preisen heutzutage für
die ganzen Fachleute die man am Bau
braucht eine Möglichkeit ist uns geilen
Effekte zu bekommen und das dann auch
wieder kalkulierbarer und bezahlbarer
also die die die die es gibt Studien
Verbände Bündnis Wohnungsbau die fordern
für den sozialen Wohnungsbau bis 25
mindestens 50 Milliarden Euro und
fördern Fördermitteln
ja also die 14,5 vom Bund werden ja
ergänzt durch die Länder in der
Vergangenheit war das immer so dass ein
Euro das Bundes anderthalb Euro der
Länder freigesetzt hat das werden wir
dann werden wir schon bei über 30
Milliarden und wir haben uns das
natürlich angeguckt jedes Jahr gibt der
Bund eine halbe Milliarden Euro mehr an
die Länder für den Wohnungsbau und die
müssen natürlich die Kofinanzierung
einstellen können das heißt Sie können
nicht in so sprunghaften Sachen einen
Bereich der fast schon mal liegen
gekommen war nämlich den sozialen
Wohnungsbau hochfahren indem sie einfach
sagen gestern gab es nichts und heute
kriegst du 20 Milliarden sondern wir
machen das mit einer langfristigen
Perspektive bis 26 dann anschließend 3,5
Milliarden jedes Jahr in Richtung der
Länder für sozialen Wohnungsbau die
Rechnung ist ja relativ banal wenn wir
es bisher geschafft haben mit den
Förderprogrammen von ich sage jetzt
immer beispielsweise 12 Euro auf 8 €
runterzufahren und jetzt haben wir eine
zielmiete von 17 Euro haben die gleiche
Förderung wollen aber nachher wieder die
8 Euro geförderte Militär es geht nicht
auf das heißt der fehlt ein ganz ganz
relevanter Betrag wenn wir weiterhin die
Miete von 8 € als geförderte Miete 10
Miete oder 7 € deutlich erhöht das was
wir nicht mehr machen ist Menschen eine
Förderung des Staates zu geben die dann
anschließend nicht auf 8 Euro runter
subventionieren sondern sich freuen und
das weiter als
eigentumswohnungsverfahren aber dabei
fällt dann auch die Mittelschicht hinten
runter der Wohnraum für die
Mittelschicht also wenn sie was ja heute
üblich ist bei einem Neubauprojekt nicht
nur 30 Prozent Sozialwohnungen
vorschreiben sondern 40 oder zum Teil 50
Prozent dann haben sie ja 50% Wohnungen
zu 6,50 € oder 6,80 € oder 8 €
vielleicht aber die anderen Wohnungen
müssen ja dann umso teurer werden um das
quasi quersubventionieren und da fällt
dann also die werden dann für 20 Euro
oder 25 Euro angeboten und da fällt für
die Mittelschicht fällt da überhaupt
nichts mehr ab also enorm unter Druck
ist diese Geschichte wegen mittig also
wenn man sich zum Beispiel Hamburg
anguckt in Hamburg sind 50% der
Bevölkerung berechtigt so ein
Wohnberechtigungsschein zu haben in
Schleswig-Holstein haben Sie jetzt einen
zweiten Förderweg aufgemacht bis zu 11 €
Miete auf einem sehr großzügigen
einkommensrahmen das
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten aber was wir
natürlich nicht mehr machen können mit
der Gießkanne jedem der ein Haus baut
und sei es ein hochpreisiges Apartment
in Berlin-Mitte auch noch Steuergelder
zu geben im letzten Jahr bevor dann
Robert Habeck diese Förderung gestoppt
hat KFW 55 sind 300.000 Wohnungen von
der KfW gefördert worden 300.000 das
heißt die komplette Jahresproduktion des
Vorjahres hatten staatlichen Zuschuss in
erheblicher Höhe bekommen das ist ein
allgemeiner Baukostenzuschuss es ist
verstehe ich dass die Bauindustrie
wieder super fand aber das kann sich
eine Volkswirtschaft von unserer Größe
nicht dauerhaft leisten und es hat auch
sämtlichen Reformbedarf weggepuffert wir
haben nicht den Digitalisierung
investiert wir haben nicht in
Vorproduktion investiert wir haben nicht
gefragt sind denn unsere Ausgleich und
Ersatzmaßnahmen überhaupt noch so
zeitgemäß organisiert dass es sinnvoll
ist und wir haben auch nicht geguckt ob
die Bauvorschriften die das Deutsche
Institut für Normung machen nicht nur
schön sondern vielleicht auch zu teuer
sind und da man Kostenrahmen gesetzt das
alles müssen wir machen das ist extrem
viel Arbeit wird auch nicht sofort gehen
aber das einfach mit ein paar Milliarden
zuzugleichen und zu sagen wir ändern
nichts und subventionieren so runter das
wird nicht gehen